[Zombelle] "This is, like, the worst article, except for, like, Lil Internet and pedobear,
it is an inside web joke that feeds off its own ridiculousness. That's pretty funny."
H∆SHTAG$ — a discussion on internet music phenomena and digital culture.
In this episode: Tumblrwave — with Kilo Kish (Tumblr rap),
Le1f (Queer Rap), and Seapunk co-founders Zombelle and Ultrademon.
[Kilo Kish] "Bloggers are so wrong sometimes about a lot of things."
[Le1f] "To see people stop labeling me as Seapunk and start labeling me as gay rap."
[Zombelle] "We don't want to be seen as, like, teens in their room trying to make web art."
[Kilo Kish] "Since I was 14, 15, I was putting up, like, pictures of myself, like..."
[Kilo Kish] "From a very early age, we're used to putting ourselves on display through the internet,
and we're really good at it."
[Kilo Kish] "As generations go on, they'll come up with innovative ways to market themselves."
[Kilo Kish] "Internet famous means that a certain group, like, age range of people
that go on certain blogs and sites would know who you are."
[Kilo Kish] "I would assume that Tumblr rap is kind of, like, DIY music.
It's, like, do-it-yourself."
"How old are you?" [Kilo Kish] "22."
"Well, that's my first question nowadays, because it's still getting younger and younger,
and accomplishing so much more."
[Kilo Kish] "I think a goal is to, like, not just be, like, famous on the internet.
That's kind of, like, lame."
[Kilo Kish] "Reblogs and hits, not really, like, an accurate measure of an artist."
[Kilo Kish] "I would hope that people would still like to listen to my music in another year,
or, like, at some other point in life."
"This reblogging aspect has really fed these artists and their fans,
and it's just really affected, you know, how people perceive it and how people dress."
[Milly McMahon / i-D Magazine] "The 90s was pop, and it was fun, and it was colorful, and we knew it was disposable.
The online tools that we use today now are in some way reflective of that."
[Nate Auerbach / Tumblr] "I think a lot of the people who criticize Tumblr and say that it's only a place for reblogging —
you're taking samples of pop culture and creating new culture."
[Nate Auerbach / Tumblr] "They might be doing the same thing with visuals.
You see that in Seapunk."
[Zombelle] "Initially, Seapunk basically was influenced by the tropical visuals,
and that did come from Tumblr."
[Ultrademon] "I really don't think it is a music genre.
I figured it was always more of, like, an ideology."
[Zombelle] "Ocean themed, but, like, punk mentality and DIY movement."
[Ultrademon] "Trying to be maybe a beacon for people to be more aware of their online identity."
[Zombelle] "No, there's, like, a misconception that, like, vacation clothing is considered Seapunk."
[Zombelle] "We're not a web joke."
[Zombelle] "We're 90s kids. Like, we have real-life reference to a certain period in time."
[Teen Witch — female member] "This building is actually from the 1890s, and we have filled it with treasures from the 1990s,
so we have the spirit of the 90s alive here."
[Teen Witch — male member] "We try to keep it going through our 20s, and those are the best memories I have."
[Daniel Dodecahedron / BlackBlackGold / GucciGoth]
"This idea that, like, oh, these people in the past had it better than us,
and now a younger generation is like, oh, I grew up in the 90s,
but I wish that I was a teenager in the 90s..."
[Daniel Dodecahedron / BlackBlackGold / GucciGoth]
"...and that has just led to this pooling of different aspects of the aesthetics."
[Teen Witch — male member, showing 90s memorabilia]
"Geri Halliwell is very important to the 90s.
It's a Left Eye, an Aaliyah candles..."
[Zombelle] "Seapunk — S-E-A-Punk — with actually the letter sea, not C, for cyberpunk."
[Zombelle] "Making your IRL dreams a URL reality."
[Daniel Dodecahedron / BlackBlackGold / GucciGoth]
"In the online world, hyper-segmentation is a creation more of the people who are writing about it,
like music journalists."
[Daniel Dodecahedron / BlackBlackGold / GucciGoth]
"I think that the people actively involved with it don't really care that much."
[Milly McMahon / i-D Magazine]
"Music is so subjective — if you put yourself out there
and you want to do something that's going to be so different,
you are making yourself extremely vulnerable."
[Le1f — showing a T-shirt]
"I just borrowed these [artist name unclear] pieces,
which anyone who's good at Tumblr has seen his work before."
[Le1f] "It's super hectic, and I'm really interested in how it has this abstract face
that is kind of clip art, is internet culture."
[Le1f] "I wore this in a music video.
I wanted to have homophobic people deal with my art in that way."
[Le1f] "I wanted to make people click on it out of interest or disgust or whatever."
[Le1f] "The internet has this level of anonymity.
People feel comfortable saying things because they can't be accountable for it."
[Le1f] "The idea of queer rap is something that didn't really even occur to me
until people started writing about it."
[Milly McMahon / i-D Magazine]
"Bringing an elephant into the room — so it's like if it hadn't been given that label
then they could just be doing what they're doing
and they'd be in the same arena as everyone else
and then you'd have really overcome something."
[Le1f] "I think what we're seeing now is a lot of interest in the archetypes falling out
into slightly more interesting, provocative, different things."
[Le1f] "Identity on the internet is an avatar.
It's about creating an avatar, creating a full character."
"Signs that people really want to express their identity.
A new personality has to come through."